حرب استنزاف منذ اكثر من 10 اشهر استهلكت
مخازن روسيا
وخزانتها في ظل الاقتصاد منكمش وعقوبات
دوليه بسبب طبعا الحرب على اوكرانيا لتكون
موسكو في بحث مستمر على اعاده تعبئه لا
تواكب الاستهلاك معظم الاحيان لتتجه روسيا
الى منتج السلع وشركات الحكوميه وتقلص
الانفاق غير الدفاعي وتحصل على ارباح اعلى
من المساهمين في الشركات وذلك في شكل دفعه
لمره واحده وفق بلوبرج نشرت في تقريرها ان
السلطات الروسيه ستسعى لارباح اعلام 50%
من صافي دخل الشركات الحكوميه اما الرئيس
الروسي بوتين فاقد تعهد بعد عدم فرده قيود
على الانفاق العسكري للحربي في اوكرانيا
وزاره الماليه الروسيه قدمت ارقاما مرعبه
بينما كانت تتوقع ان يكون العجز في
الميزان 0.9 كان الرقم في الواقع والنتيجه
للحرب اثنين بالمئه لعمليه 22 و23 اما
الانفاق العام ف اكثر بنسبه 27% مما كان
مخططا له جهد اعاده تعبئه الايرادات بات
دليلا واضحا يرقى للاعتراف بانه لا امل
لذلك رملين بالسيطره مره ثانيه على
الاجزاء الاوكرانيه التي انسحبت منها
القوات الروسيه